when you're thinking about an idea how
important is it for you to think about
the budget or are you not even
entertaining that just yet
i don't really i don't really entertain
that
when i'm trying to imagine
a story or think about what i'm going to
do in that sense i try to
let it be what it's going to be and then
try to figure out how to do it
you know i think that's the only way to
really do it because if not you're
i think you can and people do and i'm
around people who do it all the time and
we've done it i've done it where you
have these certain amount of resources
and you do it for that and yes you can
reverse engineer and kind of put
yourself into it
um but i think that this type of
exercise or this type of thought process
where it's kind of coming more
internally being broken down to your
taste
has more potential to have a sustaining
[Music]
sustaining feeling
that you can get from a project that
will sustain you through making it
whether you have to make it on your own
or you are going to get 5 or 10 or 20 or
30 or 100 million dollars to make it
because we know there are stories of all
kinds of movies that have taken many
many years for producers to get done so
the most important thing is for them to
be passionate about it and care about it
and want to see it go all the way
through especially when you're we're
talking through this type of process
anyway sure
well i don't know if we have a title for
this yet but i i love the two cards that
you've chosen maybe we could call it the
untitled sean reid project i don't know
if you have a name for it but um i think
that the the
let's call it the internal butler as a
working title so it's just just as a
just being a hollywood factory we'll
just call it the internal butler so
we're not we're not one we don't want to
say the butler because there's already
been a movie that's been the butler so
we'll just say the internal butler and
we just know that it means
the internal life of the butler but we
don't know really what that means yet
okay love it so and the internal butler
how much do you envision this movie
would cost to make
i would love to make this type of movie
for
five million dollars um
because i'd like to be able to have the
cast around it and the scope around it
but not too much but just the scope of
this
storytelling
to be able to have that that vision it
doesn't have to be that huge i mean i
don't see us hunting the dinosaur thing
and i don't see us doing the
you know the
spy thing per se but i do see you know
some adventures or some things where he
had to save or
help or rescue or
bail out the family he was working for
and in whatever way that is
you know especially once he goes on his
journey and decides to leave
you know this kind of
insular family environment that he's
discovered now that there's a secret
that he
actually does have
you know maybe he has some money and
maybe he is going to get it or maybe
they're you know or maybe
you know there's more family somewhere
whatever it is um so he's going to start
out on that journey carrying it maybe
it's even just kind of like
butlering for free you know just kind of
helping people you know you could turn
it into like a
what is that
the tv series was where is it the
wandering angel right he says or kung fu
he's just a wondering person now who's
trying to find through helping people uh
who he's supposed to be
he's not a priest he's not a he's not a
kung fu guy he's a buffer
but and even in that comedic part of it
it could be it's still serious
because people still need to like
learn how to like especially if they're
going to get a better job and they come
from a lower strata to have a butler in
your house for a week you'll learn how
to dress properly so that you could show
up for that because that butler could
show up and get that job
i mean he could show you how to dress
and tie your tie and get yourself
together to be able to go enjoy if
you've never had it and never learned
how to tie a tie never knew how to eat a
proper meal never know how to drink tea
properly or whatever it was at the time
he would be able to show you those
things sure what fork to use manners
manners get used a very long way still
in society
sure even
today oddly enough well they're often
forgotten
but anyway
cultural graces are something that you
know still can get you a lot further
than not
even just having a good tone on on the
phone can get you more than not
very true
and plus if he's helping this family who
knows if it's a a scandal maybe it's in
the paper and he ends up sort of helping
them through that anyway i'm just
there there could be many there exactly
so there could be chapters of this thing
that's why i see because that's why it's
easily a bbc show to me like i see it as
a be because it's like so it's so he's
just going and wandering around and
going and each week he ends up where
each door each season
he's helping you know first the first
season he essentially you find out the
deep dark family secret and he leaves
the next season he's now
you know on his first town or wherever
he's ended up and maybe it's you know
it's really like he's not even a butler
anymore he's you know
he's you know so he's literally fallen
out of his his life his comfort shell
you know now what will he do
you know as he a factory worker is he a
you know is he you know drinking too
much is he has he tumbled so low that
now he is not even that clean picture of
that person who is organized and can do
that
you know you have all these things that
can be happening to someone who lose
loses that protective downtime abby ish
shell
sure
if i'm but you know i'm making it
beverly i don't know what era i'm going
to make this but i'm kind of leaning
towards
when it's good
when people leave the corporate space
you know they they can also change
because now their schedule changes now
they're not seen by their title so kind
of loses part of his identity maybe yeah
he loses he loses a lot of it he loses a
lot of it so
you said five million possibly
how did you come up with that budget or
just i know it's just one small it's
based on
several things uh it is based on the
level of talent i would like to have
so if i take that and i go okay i'm
going to probably i'd want to shoot for
four weeks at that level
i would want
mainly to shoot on um
possibly in a studio i would need some
physical effects so i'm thinking 2.5
towards
casting and i'm thinking 2.5 that's 2.5
towards physical production
uh and then that's kind of how i end up
deriving it by
usually in my brain
and is much of the movie going to be him
discovering himself
or will it be in his role as this butler
with that identity
i think it's going to be with him
discovering himself through not having
an identity to be that have that
identity again or whatever that is or
whatever he chooses to choose so it's
like i think it's like that's why i like
the internal butler idea because it's
like
regardless of where he actually is he's
still butlering on some level and that's
something that he's trying to
you know
break out of
you know that in some levels he needs to
[Music]
not be thinking so much about everybody
else but discover who exactly he is and
then if he decides he wants to do that
then he could do that many butlers get
married and have fame but he's decided
to be this
you know diligent anthony hopkins
character and
which way i forget when that was but
um
where he just kind of just goes his life
just being dedicated to the to the life
and never getting married or doing those
types of things and being the best
butler they can possibly be almost like
they've got to be priests or something
sure yeah i guess it creates less
complication to the family that hires
them you know if they have no family
then there's less you know they don't
have to worry about they're there they
can go away for a day or two and then
you know they come back and they're fine
or you also become almost part of the
family when you work with absolutely you
know people that even though you you
know where you stand sort of but
you're drawn into some of the dilemmas
and squabbles and things yeah absolutely
and obviously this type of character
will be drawn into many of those
sure okay
and maybe he's a peacemaker a little bit
in a sense um
do you think this idea is ready to pitch
to investors from all the wonderful
things that you've said and these ideas
you've fleshed out no
not yet no not at all there's no there's
no i have no sense of what the
who i would put into in it
um how that would actually generate or
be worth that budget i haven't had a
chance to break down whether it be worth
distribution wise for that
um you know those types of moves this
movie is not probably unique enough if
it's a movie to get theatrical
um just based on what it is so we would
have to find a streaming service that
would be looking for this type of thing
and are they really looking for this
type of thing
um
so
i'd do some i'd have to do some i'd vet
it a lot more
uh and i'd probably look to have more of
if it was something i really wanted to
do i'd look to at least have you know a
script you know he moved the first draft
on it just because then i have a little
bit more of
i can say this is mine type of thing
especially with what we've done because
we've taken essentially we've
brainstormed anything that we could
brainstorm right now anybody else can
so the only reason that maybe somebody
could be able to go in and pitch is
because they have immediate availability
to be able to do that where i don't
necessarily have to do that i have to
figure out who it's going to be and make
a play and strategically
get to that person and it could take
time so i want to do it properly um
where someone else who's in that type of
environment they could come up with that
on the you know eat an oatmeal tomorrow
and go in and pitch that idea so it's
kind of understanding how big a pond
we're in and how immediate it is for
someone else to be able to do the same
thing so i would look to
how do i make it more mine
maybe now it's because it's like okay
well there's been the black butler but i
am a black filmmaker so maybe it's still
got to be a black butler
um maybe it's a black butler who's like
that era of like right after the jim
crowism era and maybe that becomes okay
so who is that maybe i could actually
finance it through
you know doing you know a grant through
the pba oh there's a lot of different
ways if we start to do it certain things
so that's why i start to think about it
as a development
process then you know how could i you
know get somebody to conceivably say yes
to this movie
do you have an age range for the butler
it's definitely going to skew a little
bit older um you know it's definitely
the art you know the art audience i
think it's definitely probably my you
know
my age range which is that you know
problem or the 34 to 45 55 you know type
of thing maybe some maybe you draw some
of those really artsy millennials but
you know
more than likely they may or may not be
interested in that i think they need to
a little bit more explosions or
something
not sure maybe i mean i like those types
of movies when i that's what i was going
to see merchant ivory movies at 22 23
years old but i was also going
to go see wim wander's movies when they
were opening but get that period too so
i'd go see i'd go see almost anything
if it was drawing me to see it and i'd
love to being in a theater by myself
even then so
can you give us a little more of your
vetting process what would that entail
uh in terms of something to be worthy of
taking it in or an idea
uh or a project
ultimately for me a project there's a a
few things that you have to check off
one of them is is that
do you know what's wrong with project
or do you know what someone else is
going to point out about the project
it's essentially being a good
salesperson like i want to knock down
your objections
so if you have
if some people are going to have trouble
with well you know the butler didn't do
so well and whatever well i'm going to
make it for less money and we're going
to do it this way and this is how we get
around it we're doing it do this with
the casting and open it up this way
oh okay
so
just like the question why should you
make the project
you know that's usually the first thing
it's not a it's not a challenge it's
just that there are a lot of reasons why
somebody should be making a project but
if you know exactly why you should be
making a project you convince that
person very quickly that you should be
making that project so understanding so
it's like having a checklist and taking
knocking off those objections and
knowing for yourself okay uh am i one am
i committed to this script would i be
willing to deal with this for the next
five ten years of my life i've got a
script i've been working on for that
long
you know five ten years of your life and
it's still working and i'm still gonna
get that movement and and it's really
like even the script is like i'm so
futsy uh and kubernetes you know that i
want to develop and develop and develop
where i have friends who are just go
they write the first draft and they
develop it a little bit more and then
they're ready to make it
you know and i'm just not
that type of person you know um
so
as a filmmaker as a director
um as a producer i can work with
somebody who does it however they do
things you know that's kind of i think
what's you know especially if i'm a
producer for hire
i'm hired to produce for you and that's
how you're the director and you've
already been picked i don't really have
a choice anyway right
i can try to get you to do a shot list
but you know you're already been hired i
can't really fire you we're kind of
stuck together but you know if i hired
you where i've had situations where i've
hired the director like
i've been the client has hired me to
hire everybody so i've brought the
director and or even said
if you want you could i'm like i don't
think the client's gonna take me to what
i mean i even told them look my reel's
not good enough your client's not gonna
take me
but i have somebody i just work with
they'll take him i guarantee it and i
know he'll work at my rate because i
know he needs money so you know you
figure it out and and you do those types
of things and so there's all those
different levels so when you're vetting
it one of the big things is is that
who's attached to it
already if someone's if you're bringing
me that project what does that package
look like already
i want a package to be perfectly honest
at this point
it would take a lot for me to look at
something that someone else is bringing
me outside of my own circle
mainly because
it's just so much work and it's just so
much you know personality and it's just
so much dealing with all of those
different moving parts and i've seen
i've been a part of things where there
was 100 percent that should have been
made or should have gotten sold or
shouldn't gone and because there were
too many executive producers on the
project
too many people who had influence on the
project there's no way it'll ever get
made
and i was just a creative entity and
being told that breaks your heart
you know but
you go through that and so you see it so
why would i push anything that i already
know is overloaded with too many people
right so then the other thing is
is it attached to something else is it
an original piece of property is it
an ip that has you know is it a comic
book is there something that has a value
well
i now have the reach where i have a
lawyer where yeah i could vet something
and i could get clearance i could figure
it out and i could make an offer so
that doesn't preclude me from
doing something
is it based on something historical like
what i'm working on that won't stop me
because
you got newspapers you've got all these
things if it's a real historical event
there's all this information that you
can create you don't need the book
necessarily
um
and do i see can i is it something that
i personally want to see
do i want to see it you know
and if if i can't say i want to see it
or i'm excited about it
then that would be the number one
disqualifier i would gather for
anybody i feel like i like this
character already
and i want to see his journey do we have
a name possibly for him
no we don't no no i'd have to because i
know we haven't decided on an era even
because i mean and that's where the
budget could go up like if we make it a
historical piece and we go like if you
know winter butler is really active and
are we making it in the united states
are we making it you know we're going to
uk and making it um
you know so there's a lot of different
things there's a lot of factors there
that you know can we make it all in a
studio
and say it's like because they didn't
make movies in ireland until the the
quiet man so they made a lot of movies
about ireland and europe before that and
they were all shot in the united states
so
you know we could we could do that um so
there's a lot of things to consider i
think on that
like or who would the cat like casting
might dictate that as well
sure i guess it could be a house manager
here in l.a a lot of these people have
house managers that
arrange things and and sort of run the
place yeah i mean it would be
interesting to be i mean they're
definitely like if we the 70s is still a
doable 70s 80s 90s is still very doable
as a period piece
and definitely by the 70s there were
still people who were very rich enough
and especially in beverly hills and in
different places to have and have you
know and stars and actors had butlers
um and they certainly had them in new
york um they had doormen they had
butlers they had all of those things
especially upper east side individuals
and in europe they're still alive and
kicking so you know
it's just really i think
discovering what what that sweet spot
would be